la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites reprend des couleurs la
semaine prochaine premier rendez-vous
mardi 6 juin avec une 14e journée de
mobilisation au niveau de la journée
sera ce que nous en ferons donc
j'appelle tous les personnes qui
regardent la télévision actuellement à
se mobiliser le 6 juin prochain en
nombre avec leurs collègues leurs
voisins leur famille si à la fin du fin
ils nous empêche tout simplement de
pouvoir nous exprimer librement et ben
on continuera à se battre et aux
prochaines élections aux défendra la
réforme des retraites et le retour à la
retraite à 60 ans cette bataille elle
continuera tout le temps elle s'arrêtera
jamais même si le gouvernement ne semble
pas avoir l'intention de reculer preuve
les deux premiers décrets d'application
de la réforme sont parues ce matin au
Journal officiel dont celui portant
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans moi ce
que je trouve particulièrement hypocrite
c'est tous ces manifestants ces
syndicats c'est parti politique qui
emmènent des centaines de milliers de
gens dans la rue pour s'opposer à la
réforme de retraite alors qu'ils sont
appelés à voter pour Emmanuel Macron on
voit combien depuis le début du conflit
Emmanuel Macron se sert du rassemblement
national c'est grâce au rassemblement
national qu'Emmanuel Macron passe en
force parce qu'il sait que plus le
rassemblement national est haut moins il
y a de possibilités d'alternative
politique dans le pays effectivement le
gouvernement
ne cesse d'envoyer des bras d'honneur à
un peuple qui est en mouvement à une
majorité qui n'en veut pas il est
stupide il a été dévastateur mais si
j'avais dit tiens on a traité la
présomption d'innocence par-dessus la
jambe j'aurais fait un petit geste
personne ne l'aurait vu ça passait crème
bon ce geste je le regrette notre régime
politique est en état de mort cérébrale
et que la macronie qui voulait au fond
faire qui prétendait en tout cas faire
barrage républicain est aujourd'hui en
train de faire barrage à la République
il y a eu de la part de la minorité
présidentielle et de la part de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale un
braquage démocratique un passage en
force elle s'est assis sur toutes les
règles ça révèle un effondrement de la
culture démocratique qu'est-ce que vous
demandez à y aller de Brom pivée
clairement je lui demande de laisser
l'Assemblée nationale votée parce que
nous sommes les représentants du peuple
français c'est la raison pour laquelle
je lui ai demandé un rendez-vous rapide
elle ne m'a pas encore répondu donc je
suis obligé de l'interpeller par voie de
presse vous avez demandé à la voir avant
le 8 juin et en l'état silence radio du
côté de la président de l'Assemblée
qui préférait aux Pétain ou Poutine
d'ailleurs le 6 juin prochain donc le
jour de la manifestation l'Inter
syndicale va faire sa conférence de
presse juste devant l'Assemblée
nationale ça n'est pas un hasard oui
les députés et pour interpeller il y a
une brune Pivet sur la nécessité de
voter en Inde les pelleteuses sont
entrées en action sur les lieux de la
collision mortelle qui a fait 288 morts
avant-hier les opérations de secours
sont terminées les proches des victimes
doivent désormais identifier les corps
le scénario de la catastrophe se précise
peu à peu vendredis soir un premier
train de passager et brutalement dérouté
par erreur sur la voie ou stationne en
train de marchandises des voitures
déséquilibrées sont alors projetées sur
un autre convoi qui arrive en sens
inverse zoo 8 ans atteint d'un cancer du
cerveau était invité en Corse pour le
match de l'OM le club de son cœur le
jeune garçon et ses parents ont été
agressés dans l'horloge des coups de
poing leur maillons ont été déchirés et
brûlés des on le ici réconforté par un
joueur de Marseille Matéo Guendouzi
apogée de violence d'une rencontre sous
haute tension les supporters marseillais
étaient d'ailleurs interdit de
circulation dans le centre-ville
d'Ajaccio après des heures vendredi soir
des témoins sur place sont fait état de
cris racistes avant le match une équipe
de France 3 Corse a aussi été agressé à
l'issue de la rencontre ces orages qui
se sont abattus hier soir sur Lyon et sa
métropole un véritable déluge plusieurs
rues ont été inondées des tunnels aussi
la ligne D du métro à même du fermé en
partie un phénomène exceptionnel très
impressionnant en moins de deux heures
il est tombé sur Lyon l'équivalent d'un
mois et demi de pluie